welcome to pi data global 2021. uh my
name is vasu and i'm very happy to be
here and to be your host for this
session today we have quite a stellar
array of speakers for this workshop
but i would like to remind you that
they would like to have this q a session
towards the end
so i would like to now welcome
dr james bettner and
okay welcome to the python dashboarding
shootout and showdown
uh i'm james bednar i'm the director of
technical services at anaconda and
basically what that means is that i run
a bunch of consulting projects with
different external organizations
so that's my actual job
but more relevant today is that i'm a
founding member of two groups that
me and several colleagues set up called
holovis and pi biz and these are groups
not controlled by anaconda they're
independent of anaconda
and the main hat that i'm going to be
wearing today is as pive is and kaibiz
is an organization that is just trying
to promote python data visualization of
all types of any any library any
dashboarding tool as we talked about
today
anything that helps people get their
work done in um in python so for the for
the large part i'm going to have my pi
biz hat on but i have to acknowledge
that i'm also a member of holobiz
and holoviz is one of the tools today
that we'll talk about called panel is a
holobiz tool and so uh just be aware of
my biases and background and we'll talk
about that more in a minute um but from
here and unless i'm saying otherwise i'm
here speaking in terms of pi biz
presenting the python biz ecosystem and
organizing this workshop to help people
learn more about python biz tools and
dashboarding tools in this case
so this particular workshop is about
high-level
python dashboarding tools and we had a
little discussion in slack is what is
dashboarding should we call this
dashboarding another another
term that's thrown around as web app
another is analytics app sometimes ml
app or data app
um
basically all of these tools have in
common they'll let you write some python
and then put something that someone can
use is not you can view in a web browser
and this particular workshop is focused
on high level tools there are much lower
level tools for instance panel is built
on top of bokeh and you can completely
use bokeh to build web apps directly but
this workshop is not about bokeh it's
about the higher level tools
you can also build
such tools with flask or past api or you
can build entire websites with like
shopping carts if you want with django
this
this workshop is also not about that
it's about people who've been able to do
something in python and are ready to
share it with someone usually something
involving data
it's also not about developing apps
directly in html and javascript
obviously you can always do that but
this is a workshop for python
programmers
so uh you'll be hearing from four
different
tools today and they're listed here in
chronological order and i'll just try to
give you a little bit of background
about these tools and where they come
from
first off you'll hear from
here about plotley dash that was
released in 2017 which is very popular
here these numbers are a combination of
the conda and tip downloads over the
previous month
um
[Music]
next you'll hear from panel again that's
uh that started in anaconda it's not run
by anaconda it's uh it's run by this
separate organization so in fact the
person will be defending it or
presenting it is not from anaconda
that was released later it's it looks
like only one year but i think it's more
like two years almost two years
um
and then you'll hear from uh voila uh
sponsored by but i don't know if you
would say it's controlled by you'll
probably hear more about that uh quant
stack came around a little bit later not
much um and then streamlit uh is a
company called streamlit and uh don't
pay too much attention to these download
numbers for instance voila is primarily
a server that you combine with other
things and a lot of panel users for
instance don't necessarily use a server
so the fraction of those that use the
server might be similar to voila so just
take with a grain of salt and really
just try to remember these are all
popular packages a lot of people are
using them these are not some obscure uh
side package you'll be hearing from the
leaders in the field
and who will you be hearing from
so for plotly uh that'll be the first
talk um either from nicholas christian
uh vp of product of plotline.com
uh panel uh panel is primarily a work of
my colleague uh philip rudiger it's his
brainchild and he uh stewards it uh he
couldn't be here at the last minute for
travel reasons um but uh the number two
contributor panel is here uh mark scott
madsen he um
is the lead data science scientist
developer at urstead although he can
pronounce that better than i can
um while i'll be represented by sylvain
corley who is the founder and ceo of
quantstack
and streamlet by adrian triu
al the co-founder of streaml
and it's kind of worth thinking about
right before we dive into it
just the
to put everything out in the open about
who's presenting these tools who's
pushing them who stands to benefit from
them
and uh try to balance between their
python open source and but they you want
to have a tool that's well funded and
you really you want to somehow connect
money to uh developers and get problem
solved and they each have different
models and i don't know how much people
talk about those different models
but for instance panel is primarily
funded by outside clients of anaconda
who
pay for money to give money down to
conduct for certain things to be added
to the ecosystem uh plotly um
i guess makes money on their server
products uh streamlet is new they'll
probably tell you how they make money
and so on um
while i constructed to get outside
contracts as well
so everybody can talk about about that
aspect of that and hopefully everyone
will be open and honest and uh and
uh
clear about
what drives development in the library
and how you can go forward with that
library if you choose to
all right so i'm ready to step back and
i'm just going to listen to these
presentations and then after the end of
the presentation everybody's got 15
minutes then we'll come back for
q a and discussion and comparison
between libraries and so if anyone has
any uh questions like that or discussion
topics please put it on the slack
channel and then we'll revisit those at
the uh or visit those at the end of all
the talks
so over to nicholas
all right hello everyone i'm going to
start my timer here um thanks for for
inviting me uh jim my name is nicholas
christian i am head of data
visualization at plotley i am also a vp
of product
and i'm excited to sort of talk a little
bit about dash here today
so
um jim went over some of this already we
call dash an analytical app framework
here at potley
pretty easy to install pip install dash
we're downloaded some number of times a
month um dash uh as a framework was
initiated and is supported by plotley
partly the company we also make plotly
the python library
and
dash is an mit licensed uh open source
uh library it is the open core of the
dash enterprise product that partly
sells so pili has an open core uh
business model we we develop dash and we
sell dash enterprise and are two sort of
separate things
they're just one clarification there's
no sort of free version and expensive
version of dash it's all the same dash
i'll talk a tiny bit about our
commercial offering at the end just for
clarification purposes
um i wanted to kick off with a with a
little live demo um of sort of what uh
what it's like to to to work with the
dash app so hopefully um this is big
enough to fit um
uh so here is basically code wise what a
dash app uh minimally i guess is um
you've got a couple of imports you
create the app there are two little
pieces here there is a layout
and optionally some callbacks and then
you run the app so let me kind of run
this app
and we can see what it looks like
if i run this app this is this is the
output so the layout is a little tree
here
of
of components so i've got an input
component and an h1 component
and the callbacks are a little bit like
excel formulas they uh they map inputs
to outputs and so in this particular
case i'm mapping
the children of the out component uh
there's a function that that drives this
based on the value of the in component
and what what that transformation is is
just it just says hello and so here i
can say hello you know pi data global
uh nice to meet you
um so basically what happens is every
time i type a character into this text
field that python function is called
that's what dash gives you uh you don't
have to know any javascript um to make
this work uh you don't have to write any
back-end uh you know rest methods or
anything like that you don't have to
wrangle any json you kind of lay out
what your app is going to look like here
in this layout and you wire it up with
callbacks
okay so far so good
if you run this app with debug equals
true you have this little blue puck at
the bottom here this is your developer
tools it tells you that your server is
up you don't have any errors there's a
little error panel
and you have a little uh interactive
graph here of your callbacks so here
okay yes this is basically what i've got
i've got a very simple in out
relationship
now i'm going to switch over to a
slightly fancier app um this one is
called fancy i might have to scroll a
tiny bit so this is about you know 40
lines of python it's got roughly the
same structure i'm gonna just call it
the layout here uh has an h1
a drop down and then two graphs and then
i have two callbacks the first callback
uh binds the drop down to the graph and
the second one finds the drop down and
the first graph to the second so
let me just kind of run this and show
what that can look like to make it a
little clearer
so
the the app has reloaded and in this
particular case i've got a drop down a
scatter plot and a map
and the the the callback graph
for this has been a little bit confused
but i can sort of tease it out um and
i've got my
this isn't worth spending time on um but
i've got my my graphing so i can change
the the year that i'm presenting data
for and you can see everything updates
and i can make a selection over here
and that selection is reflected on the
graph below so this is kind of an
example of what you can do uh with the
dash app the callbacks i hid them just
because the
visual noise but they're not very long
the first one basically just displays
the scatter plot filtered by the drop
down and the second one displays a map
filtered by the selection of the
previous one
so mostly what i wanted to show here is
that you can put lots of different
things in your in your layout um and
anything can be an input anything can be
an output
so that's what a dash app sort of
minimally has to be um and i'm going to
switch back to my deck for a second here
to to just kind of highlight you know
there's the layout which is basically a
tree of dash components that have props
and then callbacks any component can be
an input or an output
i also wanted to give you a sense of
what a dash app can be
by showing you dash apps sort of some
some in the wild some of our demos so
dash apps can be dashboards sort of
typical you know dashboard types
presentations you zoom in things filter
this is using dask and datashader for
sort of large data processing
so this is a typical kind of dashboard
style app where you're making selections
and querying a static data set uh you
can have this nice interactive graph
dash apps can be printable reports this
is a
an example from our gallery
this is a multi-page app so each page of
this printable report has its own
dedicated url
and you can have a full view where you
can kind of scroll through you can hit
command p
on a mac and this thing will print
control p on windows
so a dash app can uh can power a
printable report
uh a dash app can be a slide deck uh you
can have components that look like uh
that looks like slides and you can sort
of connect these things to live data
sources if you want um
here i'm just gonna play like two
seconds of this youtube video without
sound a dash app can be a very
sophisticated workflow tool with dozens
of drop downs and this sort of like
multiple step thing where you've got you
know select a file and check the
messages and multi-file plots so it can
be a multi-step uh you know wizard type
thing that produces dozens of charts
sends emails
whatever you want so there's some some
interesting bioinformatics stuff going
on here
uh dash apps can be scientific
communication tools so this is a
beautiful
application that was released alongside
a paper in nature
and we're increasingly seeing scientists
basically like publishing papers and
then and then publishing dash apps
alongside to give folks access to the
data or algorithms that their papers are
about
so this entire thing here is a dash app
including the user guide which is pretty
cool
and then the last thing is dash apps can
be kind of fun and engaging this is like
a retirement planner you know it's like
you
you say you want to retire at 59 you hit
go
and this thing will generate a nice
attractive little report for you um
at least i did earlier yeah so you've
got your sort of expected wealth over
time various different things these are
all sort of data driven based on the
calculator that was above and you've got
some extra charts that you can make
so that's what a dash app can be
and i know i'm kind of doing the thing
where it's like draw two circles and
then draw the rest of the owl but you
have to kind of believe me that
all of these apps that i showed you are
basically built out of these these two
primitives you've got it a tree of dash
components with props and you've got
callbacks that wire them up um so
hopefully that can be a little bit
inspiring in terms of what can be um
i'll have a link to this deck at the
very end here
so to give you a sense of who uses dash
uh you know we we have direct reports
and direct communications with with sort
of python first timers who are really
excited they've picked up python and ash
and bit of as m pi data all at once uh
and they're really excited and some some
python old hands um who dash is for uh
data scientists scientists engineers
analysts uh people working in finance
pharma energy utilities government sport
media tech um there's not really you
know a vertical that the dash is sort of
specifically for uh and and we're really
seeing folks using dash and sort of uh
all of the different departments of of
these organizations so
if you see yourself on this deck you
know dash is for you if you don't i'm
sorry i missed you um but uh but uh but
you know it really is intended to be a
general-purpose tool
so let's get let's get down to brass
stacks dash is back-end architecture so
dash is built using flask
under the hood
and therefore you can deploy a dash app
anywhere you can deploy a flask app it
deploys on heroku it deploys on any
cloud host we have you know users and
customers that have deployed a dash app
pretty much anywhere you can think of
dash's back end has a totally stateless
http
type of pattern so each of the callbacks
that are written are sort of pure
functional callbacks they can be
executed by any worker if you have a
load balancer in front of a dash app you
can have dozens of workers spread across
you know 10 or 12
machines if you want and you can just do
a round robin kind of distribution it's
trivial to scale horizontally
dynamically you can just add workers or
remove them
[Music]
to to a kind of a cluster of running
dash apps or you can just you know run a
single dash app with g unicorn and use
three or four processes or something
like that to handle load so this is sort
of one of the big strengths of dash is
this stateless architecture
uh and uh i guess it's implicit in the
the little app that i showed you but
there's no limit to the library
libraries that you can use you know you
can use search you can use uh tensorflow
whatever it is you want you have full
access to the python code the promise
that dash makes is that whatever the
user does in the browser we'll call the
python function that you have asked to
be called
and whatever that python function does
is up to you connect to databases call
apis run things
so long as it's a kind of a pure
functional operation
dash dash will work
dash's front-end architecture uh is
built on top of react we published a
cute little article that says you know
dash is react for python that gives you
some people um so so dash is built using
react and the reason we said that dash's
react for python is that any react
component can be turned into a dash
component we have a
a system called the dash component
boilerplate you kind of annotate your
react component you know turn the crank
and out comes a dash component
so that tree that layout
that layout tree
can contain anything that can be a react
component so out of the box we have um
you know every html element has been
wrapped we have a
bundle of components called the dash
core components which includes sort of
inputs and drop-downs and sliders and
graphs which are powered by plotly uh
the graphing library
and sliders and so on so there's a bunch
of first party components that come with
dash
first party being being plotly i guess
the people who made it
and alongside plotley maintains some
other libraries such as cytoscape.js
dash component for network
visualizations dac for we call it data
acquisition but it's basically a bunch
of widgets that look like physical
widgets uh we have dash bio which is a
set of bioinformatics focused components
we have wrapped vtk working with the
developers of vtk for high performance
scientific visualization and there are
also third-party components so the
community has really stepped up and
there's a there's a company maintaining
a bootstrap uh set of components for for
styling your app um some people you know
really like leaflet as opposed to the
the plotly powered maps
so they've built um dash leaflets set of
components so it's pretty easy to to
make a react component into a dash
component and there's lots of people
doing that
and not sharing the results many of our
customers will have custom components
in the apps that they're building
the dash ecosystem is also pretty broad
you know i'm here at pi data uh i love
python uh we have a back end for for for
python um but the the front end can be
connected to
you know any kind of back end and so we
have a back end for r we have a back end
for julia we have back end for f sharp
so this is a you know a broader
ecosystem and folks who are using other
languages are able to leverage all the
same set of front-end components uh from
their language of choice and we have
made it such that the
the various back-ends are sort of you
know mutually compatible in terms of
design so you can kind of move back and
forth and reuse some of the principles
that you uh you have learned
dash supports any graphing library in
principle
any of the graphing libraries that exist
in the python ecosystem can be wrapped
in a react component therefore a dash
component i've done it
most of our users use plotly in practice
definitely you know this is what we use
in our documentation uh the dash team
and the plotly team back in back in the
day when you know i wasn't sitting in my
spare bedroom all the time we used to
sit a few meters from each other um so
so definitely uh you know plotly is the
one that's best documented but there's
not any technical limitation for any
other graphing libraries
for developing uh dash applications in
jupiter we have a lookalike package
called jupiter dash which you sort of
drop in instead of dash
and you can build applications in
jupyter although i will say most people
do build
do build their dash apps in something
like the s code or or pycharm
a dash app when you deploy it you know
runs from a python file um and uh and
you know this is this we call these apps
they they really are intended to be sort
of like software engineering and
deployed and testable
um and then finally a big part of the
dash ecosystem uh is our dash enterprise
product so dash enterprise basically
adds to dash open source um we add you
know deployment uh tooling some
infrastructure some additional
components and support from plotley so
there is nothing limited we have not
crippled dash open source dash open
source is a is a powerful you know uh
heavily adopted tool every single one of
our enterprise customers uses dash open
source every day it is the core of dash
enterprise it is uh supported by plotley
our business model you know we sell
software we sell dash enterprise and we
sell support for dash enterprise and we
reinvest an enormous amount of that
money into uh into the open source
ecosystem be that the dash core the
plotly graphing library any of the
components answering questions on the
forum
etc so that's a little bit about the
ecosystem
we are almost over you may have one
minute
one minute that's all i need
so to get started uh just visit dash.com
if you want to see more cool apps uh
with source available go to
gallery
we have a very active community forum at
community.plotli.com
uh where people my favorite part of this
is the show and tell where people post
the apps that i then come and show it
talks like this
if you want access to this slide deck so
you can click on these links yourself go
to bit.li
slash pdg pi data global pdg hyphen dash
um
that is the link to this and i am i'm
really excited to be part of this panel
uh hear what the other what the other
folks have to say and then and then have
a nice positive discussion and all in my
last 15 seconds say thanks to jim and
say that i'm very proud to be part of a
community where where we do this kind of
thing and and have these fun sessions
and
sort of exchange like this so so thanks
to the other panelists as well
thank you nicholas really great
presentation
so my name is mark and i'm here to give
an introduction to panel and thanks for
taking the time
so
what you see here is actually a panel
app and that's what i'll be doing for my
talk i'll be using a panel app so you
can find actually this app at my github
site mark's commerce and awesome panel
introduction
and you really should check it out
because you can find all the code and
you can also open the app right now on
binder and also find the code on binder
so back to the presentation so a little
bit about me
so i'm here actually
i'm not working for a company called
panel or something like that or for
anaconda i'm working for a company
called ester i'm not representing ursula
here
in this talk i'm representing my myself
and my passion which is data apps
but
just to tell you a little bit about my
employer
so erster is ranked the most sustainable
energy company in the world three years
running
it's the leading offshore wind
company and it's also
becoming a renewable energy major as we
speak
check it out
um a little bit more about me you can
check out my site
data models analytics so there's a
little bit on me about me you can see me
here i'm working for traders this is not
traders investors this is just a general
picture but i'm working for traders
every day and it's a fast-paced
environment with a lot of data a lot of
visualizations and a lot of things
changing all the time we make a lot of
small apps all the time
some of these apps stay around some are
thrown away the day after
so
in order to support use cases like that
and also
to support
a medium-sized company where we have
engineers we have analysts we have
scientists we have data scientists we
have tear-ups we have machine learning
experts
i was looking for a data app framework i
wanted something where it's really easy
to
use the application in twin
in a lot of situations so both for data
exploration
i'm really into data exploration not
only making charts but i really want to
make them interactive with small widgets
like sliders or drop down or something
like that so i can really
filter in and focus and discuss with
myself and my colleagues
also in twin in the sense that it should
reach production it should be really
easy to get to production
so getting things out as a report a
static report or an interactive web app
and it's python we are talking about
here
so
i wanted something that could bridge
that as well i wanted something where
you can easily build a lot of apps like
a multi-page app so what you see is
actually a multi-page app it's pretty
easy i just have 10 python files each is
a
python application a panel application
and then you can start it up
and maybe we should actually take a look
how does
something like an application look so
here we have a simple application
it's actually cbone
and you can just change the color of the
plot it's not really advanced this might
be like the output from a machine
learning model instead and you want to
play around with some of the arguments
to the function
but the key thing is i can use c-bone
here because i was also looking for
something where i can work together with
my colleagues in trend some people
prefer or need matplotlib for their use
cases
some people
need or preferred bokeh some plotly some
people prefer each art for example
because they are nice like to
transitions when you change the plot
right it looks really fresh and modern
and i wanted something where you can
sort of take
python's database end-to-end and grab
layer collaborate on and and this panel
provides as well i want something and
you'll see that where you can really
build like streaming streaming
applications
i wanted something where beginners in
python could work for example in
notebooks because that's often where
they start out so you can build
pen labs or do exploratory data analysis
with panel in notebooks and we'll see
that
i also because i'm an old grumpy coder
you could say i want to work in vs code
and i want to be efficient there and i
have a lot of colleagues working in
pycharm and i want a framework that
supports all these use cases
so let's get back to the introduction
so no matter
where you are especially like if you're
a domain expert somehow then the panel
is something something for you
i run two sites so i run
awesomepanel.org and
awesomestreamlit.org so i think you
should check them out as well
um
so one of the promises and something i'm
really pretty interested is in is that
this really works with the tools you
know and love so
we can check some of this out python's
this
so as you can see here you might see
your favorite plotting library here
let's take a take a look and see okay
this is celtir
this is pokey this is
tectile it takes a little bit to load
but it's really nice
e-charts
pretty nice
volume
and so on
and if you are out there if you
are working with a repository i made and
open the app you can find all the code
for each example here you can just drop
that in and run it
so we also support bloodley of course
plot nine
pi day
and so on
this template that you see here
it's also pretty nice it's not something
you have to develop because i want my
applications to look smooth
right i'm going to communicate with
colleagues or stakeholders or customers
and it just needs to to look nice so it
should be really easy to make nicer
applications
because
i need to communicate and sell
my things and that's also one thing i
would like to say today actually that no
matter which data app framework is your
favorite i believe you should look into
data app frameworks it's a superpower
for you and your team to be able to
master a data app framework because then
you can really explore your data and you
can really showcase it to your
colleagues and stakeholders again so you
can get out there with your data and
your models and get feedback and iterate
that's really important
one of the promises that's also pretty
important for me is actually that we're
bridging here so we can actually use
ipad widgets i just put in a few here
for example you can use ipad leaflet if
you're into ipad leaflet that's a really
advanced and complex library it's really
really really powerful
but here put in ipad sheets and you can
see here we have a
slider and yeah it reacts to this
and we have ipi widgets as well
and yeah we can use them
one of the things i was also looking for
was like highly reactive
applications i wanted
i wanted to be able to react to events
from my plots like
hover and click and stuff like that so
a lot of these plotting libraries like
call of use or plot your echarge
provides that and i can use that with
panel that's pretty amazing
so for example here we are looking at
hollow views and if you have not heard
of holoviews it's a part of hollowvis
which is an ecosystem of data
visualization tools
of which panel is a member and all these
tools integrate really nicely with panel
so here you can see we have nice
interactivity here we can
make our own data our own chart and we
have
reactivity bindings here
similarly
here we have h3plot what is hvplot you
might ask but this is a data
visualization library that should make
it really easy for you to make
interactive parts so what's the easiest
way and most well-known way that's the
pandas plotting api so pandas.plot or
dataframe.plot and it's actually the
same hp plot is appendest.plot api so we
have a data frame called sprint and then
we just instead of writing dot plot we
write dot h v plot and then we get a
nice island plot
one of the
true gems or unique things of the
holovis ecosystem something that's
unique in the python data ecosystem is
data sheet
and what problem does datasheet solve it
solves the problem of big data right we
get more and more data
like millions of rows or billions of
rows where we need to apply
desk or
cuda or
something like that in the background to
work with them but we also want to
visualize it and that's what data shader
enables us to do it can really like
visualize
terabytes of data at cern or places like
that
and just to to tell you that
i really believe that that's a really
stronghold of panel the strong
integration with datasheeter is that for
example
rapids they build big data visualization
framework on top of panel and data
sheeter so
rabbits built this cox filter
on top of panel and bokeh and dl and all
stuff and if you look at it here you can
see this is actually panel apps
highly interactive on big amounts of
data and i think they're pretty nice
then there is prem and param is powerful
parameters for your applications
it's actually what
one of the things i really like about
working with panel is that
it
it makes it easy for you to make a
reusable components right you can say
this is
this is a domain model
this could be anything it could be in
finance a black shield model or
something like that here's just addition
we have two parameters a and b
and we have a resulting
function that here returns a string but
it could also return matplotlib or
whatever and panel will like magically
display it
and if we look at the code
param
so
all it is is really we have a class you
can think of it as a data class
we
sprinkle in a little bit of parametric
param.parametrized define our parameters
as a number and an integer and it says
it actually matters because now we have
validation a is a floating number and b
is an integer and if somebody inputs
something else
we will get validation errors
and one more powerful thing is that a
panel can use this
because we don't have to tell or think
about which widgets we'll use panel can
just magically
say
panel.param on this class and then we
get widgets and then we can place our
widgets inside a column together with
the resulting output function here and
we will get
a nice
function like this so it means we can
build like libraries of domain models
independent of panel but we can quickly
visualize using panel
and panel of course is a part of
all of this
so you can build nice dashboards for
example
so again
let's take an example app just to
to look at the code how does code like
this look
so we could try this one
so this is this really illustrates often
what is the problem the problem is
really we have some code it has nothing
to do with data apps or panel or
anything here the example is somebody's
favorite plotting library is cbon
and they've made a function here with an
argument input argument a green caller
and can we
and that's the function that they have
then they want to make it interactive
and that's where we can sprinkle in a
little bit of magic from panel
we always need to run pn.extension so
panel.extension
and we want to sprinkle in a drop down
or select widget here with a default
color value and some colors we can
choose from
and we want to make this function
interactive so we can bind that function
to the widget that's what you do here
and then we wrap it up in a nice
template
give the template some nice colors and
so on and
we put our select
widget in the sidebar and the
interactive function in the main
and then we run panel serve the name of
the script
and then we get a nice application that
we can
work with let us just check it out
yeah and this is the application that we
saw in the beginning
and for me at least it's not a lot of
code you have to
to do in in order to
to get something like this
so mark reminder that only one more
minute would be left
yeah thanks then i'll just wrap up
important for me is also that it just
works in your notebook and id so here
you have juvederm you have collab
you have vs code
the interactive environment
you have
vs code like python files
old grumpy code like me i'm using this
and the good thing is whenever i save my
code it just updates over here
so that's pretty nice
and
yeah
one important kind of application is
really the cross filtering
that is pretty easy to make
an application like this
with panel
so you have nice cross filtering here
like that and if we go back
then i will
finalize by saying you should check out
some of these nice resources so check
out the panel site
really nice there's a getting started
guide a user guide a reference gallery
and so on you should check out panel on
github and give it a star i think it
deserves it
and yeah check out some of these other
links but if you are into like nice
interactive gears gifs check out the
panel on twitter and you'll see a lot of
the different like use cases for for
panel illustrated by the community
and when you start out
you should also go to the
to the communist site
to get help
or just showcase what you can do so go
here and showcase what you can do
that's a nice and inviting place to be
so thank you for your time
thanks a lot mark
um moving on i would now like to invite
silver
okay thanks everyone so uh let's talk
about voila uh but before talking about
vola i'd like to talk about myself a
little bit i hope that you all
understand my quaint french accent
so my name is silva corley i'm the
founder and ceo of quant stack so for
those who don't know cronstack it's a
paris and berlin-based
software
development company
we are
we essentially socialize in open source
software for scientific computing the
team comprises
about 10
core developers of jupiter and we're
also very active in the contact forge
ecosystem
and as an open source developer i'm
personally very involved in the jupiter
project
and i'm one of the co-developers and
co-creators of voila i also do a lot of
volunteer work in the community i'm a
one of the members of the board of
directors of non-focus and also
organized the pad at paris meetup
last year i was the vice chair of gp2con
which was an online conference about
jupiter
in late
2020 um
so
before i get into voila let's
have a quick word about jupiter so
what's jupiter i think most people know
it but
jupiter more than just a notebook it's a
collection of interoperable tools for
interactive computing
so it's really meant to address
all of the stages of a scientist
workflows from the exploratory phase of
their work to the presentation of their
results so it's a collection of open
standards more than a single application
and a single implementation for a
concept like the notebook
we actually
devised a well specified set of file
formats protocols so that anyone can
replace a component of the stack and
still interoperate with the rest of them
and most importantly it provides a
notebook which is a document-oriented
interface for discovery and
documentation and the notebook was
credited as being one of the first
implementations of the literate
computing paradigm by of donald knuth
where users actually
mix
narrative
content with executable code producing a
content that you know where you can
carry
a reasoning and you know have you know
and the explanation of the program
alongside it and outside the source code
um so one
uh extension point of the jupiter
ecosystem is the jupiter widgets
ecosystem so what what jupiter widgets
are there are special objects
that have a an interactive
representation like a visual
representation
in the jupyter notebook or in other
jupiter-based frontals
so initially it was really meant to
serve like as a small set of controls
that you could put next to a plot so
that you can change some parameter and
see the impact of that parameter on the
outcome of your of your computation
but actually from the start we built it
as a framework that you can build upon
right and today there is a vibrant
ecosystem of custom widgets like ipygani
for 3d plotting so there is a nice
animation at the
lower left corner of ipagani with like
some wave simulation bq plot is a
plotting library that was built upon
widget's
ipad volume for volume rendering hyper
lift
for maps
uh i think that the current plotly
python
library actually is built upon ipad
widgets today
which was a huge vote of confidence for
for the framework
ipad webrtc for video streaming we've
got graph library there is like a really
vibrant ecosystem of such libraries
and that are really nicely interpreted
with each other because you can bind any
attribute of such a library with
the equivalent attribute of another
library and like make complex
applications using all of them together
so
the thing is
when you try to communicate with
notebooks
notebooks can be great for you know
working your audience through your
reasoning as you're trying to explain
how you build
a program like for example for class
but
it's not the best tool for all audiences
for example the one of the main issues
that people experience with the books is
that the most interesting content tends
to be in the end because that the stuff
that you are building in the notebook
and like the nice job that you want to
show to everyone is in the end and by
then you may have lost half of your
audience especially those who don't want
to see code
and
also if you really want to offer the
full interactivity of widgets to end
users
if you actually are using the notebook
you actually need to provide an
execution environment for the use of the
book so that they can move sliders and
interact with the camera so that's
another issue in terms of security and
finally if the audience that you want to
show your results to is not interested
in seeing the code but only the
narrative content and the features then
you're also in bad shape so some people
built some plugins to the notebook to
hide the code and to change the layout
but he didn't quite strike it because he
didn't resolve the
execution model and how we could just
you know securely share these
applications
and yeah so there were lots of
challenges
so essentially we need tools to look at
the book differently
so i wanted to point i'm going to send
the link after um to a blog post that we
recently published
on the jupiter blog by marina baranes
about looking at notebooks
uh with different glasses i think this
was a really nice blog post summarizing
all of you know the current tooling
that's available
for in the jupiter ecosystem
so now let's get into voila
so voila transform notebooks into
standalone applications so it can be
deployed securely to serve content
publicly
and it also provides a templating system
allowing authors to change the notebook
layout and turn the books into either
like interactive dashboards with a rich
layout or slideshows or just like a like
a one-page document
really looking like a notebook without
the input areas
so voila is also and that is really
something i want to emphasize
more than is like a separate drawer from
the jupiter ecosystem vola is really a
jupiter story
we didn't build voila from the ground up
like on the side we reused existing
components from the gp2 ecosystem
so the notebook format the kernel
protocol the end becomes the template
and a lot of the improvements to the
underlying components over the past
couple of years were motivated by voila
so basically what i helped a lot improve
and be converted all of the jupiter
stack
so
basically vola is very interoperable
with a jupiter ecosystem and one
important aspect of jupiter
uh that is key like it's one of the most
popular extension points is that jupiter
is agnostic to the programming language
you can
write you can use you know jupiter
kernels for c plus plus or lua
or many other languages and it's also
the case with voda and i think that roda
is probably unique in that way in that
it's a language agnostic dashboarding
tool you can make a dashboard in c plus
plus using polar
so how do you use water here i have a
very simple python notebook with a bicup
figure
and you know it's interactive so there
is some you know zooming and panning
happening like that requires some
launching to the back end in this case
and you can try it locally very easily
by just typing voila and the name of the
notebook and it will spawn a small web
server on your machine
and you know just
serve your notebook
in an interactive fashion
and you can still do all of the things
that you were doing within the book even
if it requires some computation the back
end if you were doing i don't know some
analysis some pca whatever it may be
it works exactly the same as in the
notebook
and essentially so voila executes the
notebook and provides you with the
kernel but in order to share it securely
the way it works
is by changing and turning around the
execution model so in the case of voila
essentially the main difference is that
the front end doesn't send any execution
request there is no arbitrary code
execution all it does is asking for a
specific notebook to be executed and
then the backend is going to serve the
rendered notebook progressively and keep
the kernel around for the user so that
you can
you know stay on the page and interact
with the widgets and the kernel will
only be shut down if you are idle for a
long period of time or if you close the
tab
uh so yeah i already insisted on
language agnosticism in this example i'm
showing a c plus plus
uh notebook that's using the
zeus clean kernel that's a simple spruce
kernel based on the clean sea busbas
interpreter that was developed at cern
and you know this king supports
interactive widgets and here i'm making
a very simple application where you can
draw an ipad leaflet map and like get
some you know c plus plus call back and
uh so if you are really uh if you really
have trouble with python and you prefer
cpus press you can write all of this and
there is no python even whatsoever in
that dashboard
so you're safe
[Music]
um so another important project of that
ecosystem is the voila gallery so it's a
voila gallery is actually a jupiter hub
extension
uh so it was announced by jeremy tulu on
the jupiter blog like some time ago and
there there is a lot of development in
that space at the moment so we are
working on the binder base for the
gallery right now
so you can either deploy the gallery as
a binder extension or as a jupiter hub
extension
another extension point to voila is the
template system
so essentially
uh
when rendering notebooks to the user
uh you can
actually apply some you know templating
system so that you can change the layout
or you know change the appearance of
of
like add some css or add like a header
footer anything you want like a logo for
a company
and so we have a fairly generic
templating system that extends the one
of nb convert
and a collection of fairly actively
developed templates so one is voda
beautify which is a 55.js based template
which is very i would say mobile
friendly
we have what a grid stack which is a
dashboard template where you can
rearrange uh widgets and in in a complex
fashion and voila reveal which is meant
to produce slideshows so i didn't have
the
elegance
of mark to use voila to make my
presentation about vola but maybe i
should have
um
and so what a good stack is this one i
was talking about which is a means to
you know rearrange a notebook source in
with a complex layout the layout being
saved to the notebook metadata so that
when you open it with voila you get the
layout in rendered as expected
and we also have a visual editor for
grid stack templates that integrates
well with jupiter lab
and produces
search interactive dashboards
and this one
is a
dashboard about flavors of scotch that
was produced by ibm a long time ago for
another project that was called jupiter
dashboards and i actually used that one
that one dashboard for this example
because we decided to keep the same
layout format as the original project by
ibm so that we can render all of the
original dashboards from the dashboards
which is a duplicated project
what i reveal is this template for
turning notebooks into slideshows
beautify is a mobile-friendly template
that works really well
in combination with the ipad beautify
jupiter widgets library
and now let's talk about the future so
in the next release of voila we are we
have
already merged actually and it's that we
are in the prerelease cycle for this
release
we enable the kernel hard pulling so
that um
voila dashboards rendered a render
immediately because we have a pool of
pre-rendered dashboards
ready for for the user
we're also working on enabling jupiter
light kernels to have pure web assembly
dashboards that execute fully in the
browser so if you're aware of jupiter if
you're not aware of gifted lab should
definitely check it out jupiter lite is
a distribution of jupiter lab that works
entirely in the browser including the
long question also including python and
it's based on a python distribution
compiled to web assembly called biodied
so yeah you should definitely google
that jupiter light
and uh in the long term we'll be working
on the collaborative editing features
for the voda grid stack layout editors
and
also doing some experimentation about
having voila dashboards that enable some
collaboration collaboration features for
example you may have presence you may
see other users cursors that type of
stuff
and finally
uh it's not a one-man show there are
lots of developers who contributed to
to voila and i wanted to highlight the
names in the last slide
and that's it for me i hope i didn't go
over it seems not
great thanks a lot sylvain i would now
hand it over to each fool
hi everyone um great to be here uh thank
you so much for your time i also want to
point out that marissa smith is here
from streamlit on our community team uh
she helped me prepare this presentation
and so uh hi marissa so uh yeah very
happy to be here um thank you so much
jim for inviting me um and i also want
to say i just really love the tone of
this um this whole presentation i uh
i uh you know i'm a former academic and
i love the python community and i love
the sort of academic feeling and and
seeing all the commonalities and
actually how all of these technologies
are built on very similar stacks so
very happy to be here um and especially
at pi data why because two years ago
streamlit was launched at pi data la
back when you could actually go
somewhere and see people
and i
showed uh this thing called streamlit
and i also showed you guys a super janky
demo uh which we're going to re-uh
revisit a little bit today um and uh and
so since then uh over the past two years
uh it's really been amazing uh streamlit
has taken off incredibly we've just
launched a whole bunch of really cool
features uh the response in the in the
community has been amazing and so it's
kind of a wonderful to come back here
two years later and especially on the
eve of another uh or right after i
should say another big milestone for us
which is the launch of one point out
which is basically
for us it means that uh the original
vision for which dreamlet could be we'll
get into that super easy way to turn
your python scientific scripts into apps
uh
has been the initial story has been uh
complete
and so uh i wanted to just share with
you guys a cool video
which kind of shows a little bit uh the
journey that we've been on since the
original pi data presentation of
streamlight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cool so uh yeah a whole bunch of stuff
has happened uh uh over the past uh uh
year and i want to share two years i
want to share a lot with you but i want
to take a step back and just um first of
all introduce myself and say hello so
i'm adrian i'm the co-founder and one of
the co-creators of streamlit the open
source project um and i have a
background actually as an academic so i
was a professor at carnegie mellon
university and then i went over to
google x and started helping with
self-driving cars and other crazy
scientific projects i went over to
zuke's and and helped them build
self-driving cars and then in 2018
founded streamlets and
launched it in 2019
and i guess the point here is that um
i have seen a lot of
machine learning groups and been in a
lot of machine learning groups at the
time and uh over these years and um
and so i kind of created uh streamlets
uh the original idea was just to make it
really simple to
take a script that you were writing and
these could be uh data transformations
uh but it also could be just sort of
like the the scripts that you have lying
around in your computer uh and the
python script that you have laughing
around your computer and make those
visual in some way make the ability to
see how they're operating see what's
going on in all the matrices and the
numpy arrays and the data frames
and actually play with them
without having to go through a sort of
tedious
rewrite edit the code that's part of the
flow as well but you want a way to
be able to play with these things and
then share with them
share them with others and the result is
uh i think a tool that's been
really remarkably useful uh not only for
simple uh you know dashboarding style
use cases like the one that you see on
the left but also uh for just sort of
general python computation and in
particular machine learning which is my
background and i just want to call out
something i wanted to show you guys this
video because it's so cool but then i
was like there's probably some copyright
issues or something but anyway go to
project strike a pose uh on google
and uh it's a it's a it's a uh adobe
project that was released yesterday and
it's just so mind-bending uh here we
have a source image and then you can add
a target pose which is just an image and
then it generates a new image
which is of that source person but in
the target pose just completely
mind-blowing stuff uh really incredible
um the least impressive thing by far is
that it was created in streamlit and you
can actually see there that's a
streamline interface
and and actually i'm sort of very proud
of the fact that that's the least
impressive part of the demo and that's
kind of the whole part point of
streamlit uh which is that it sort of
fades into the background and lets you
just think about your the code itself
and so uh as uh jim invited me to give
this presentation i was it actually
really was a moment for me to reflect
about well what is it that uh that i
think makes streamline special and why
uh is it you know the integration with
this or that library or is there
something deeper and i really came down
to two ideas that i want to share with
you guys uh the first one is simplicity
and the second one is community and
really there's a lot more to both of
these than you might think
so i'll start off with uh simplicity and
give a quote from travis oliphant who's
uh
the father of numpy and scipy and i
think probably
as responsible as anybody for the
creation of the entire python data
ecosystem which we are all
uh thriving in and and hopefully working
together to grow
and he had a super interesting uh talk
with uh lex fridman
another hero of mine a couple weeks ago
that i listened to and he said something
interesting about python that i think
really hit the nail on the head why is
python so special is it because it's
really amazing at multi-threading no
actually that it has a global
interpreter like and it's like kind of
terrible and multi-threading but somehow
it is turned into the most spoken
programming language in the world and
has this huge effect not only in the
data world but devops in education and
other places and what he said was python
let's you do
wait a minute i'm getting this wrong
python lets you do a lot without
demanding a lot of you
it lets you think
lets you think
and that to me
that is really it when you're coding in
python and or when you're coding in many
other languages i feel like you're
thinking a lot about programming you're
thinking a lot about the abstractions
and somehow when you're coding in python
you're actually thinking about the
domain the whole time and that to me is
so special and that's really
the special thing about python that i
wanted to
carry into streamlet and so okay what is
streamlist for those of you who don't
know
it's a way to turn python scripts into
interactive
web apps
and um
it's super easy to get started you can
pip install streamlit and then you can
type stream it hello and it gets you
started from there
um and uh
and then it's based on very very simple
principles and i really liked actually
uh the way nicholas talked about the
simple principles underlying um
uh underlyingly dash uh and and
similarly for streamlit we try to really
minimize what you have to think about so
the first one is just embrace python
scripting so every streamlit app is just
a python script it is
native python you can in fact python it
uh and it'll run as an ordinary script
and also you could streamlet run it and
then it'll run as something visual
the second one
is treat widgets as variables so we just
want you to inject wherever your script
needs to sort of change or branch you
can just inject one line of code you
don't have to think about
sort of as an app developer you think
just as a python programmer as a data
script developer
and the final one is uh that we provide
some primitives that let you reuse code
over time this is a little bit the way
um a uh i'm forgetting the word but the
way of a cell works i think that's the
word in um in uh in jupiter
and uh it's super easy to add a whole
bunch of other interesting cool things
uh we've worked really hard like python
itself to make sure that stream that is
completely batteries included so out of
the box it works with all of the major
uh you know plotting libraries and again
i have to say you know listening to this
talk and listening to you guys all talk
uh it's very inspirational to see how
really this is actually just one
community and all these all these
technologies are interrelated so so so
deeply
um
and uh and uh finally you can really go
crazy and connect these primitives away
put together in a bunch of interesting
ways and i'll talk a little bit more
about that later uh over the past two
months we've uh released a whole bunch
of amazing fun things that make
streamline more beautiful
that let you
understand how to use it better
let developers and viewers interact with
their apps differently
and also i'm very excited to announce
that next tuesday we're going to be
launching stream like cloud so actually
jim i really appreciated the way you
said you know all of these companies and
projects are supported financially in
different ways and that's a really
important part of the of the of the of
the story and i've really learned that
that's true you know streamlined started
off um actually as an open source
project it was not meant to be a company
and it became a company when we saw some
engineers that we were using it and
we're like oh wow there could be
something here
the open source project is very very
dear to my heart and um
uh
and uh and so it's you know similar to
plotly the project itself is is is sort
of independent of the company and we
support it as a community project and
also we build a bunch of really cool
tools to let you uh uh share your
streamled apps and deploy them and do
additional neat things on top but the
core streamline library is the same for
everyone
and so i wanted to show you guys a quick
demo of that
and so i must go back to the original uh
demo that i shared at street at pi data
two years ago this is it uh it looks a
little cooler now because we've added
some cool stuff uh and so what i'm gonna
do is grab this github repo
and i'm gonna go over to
share.streamlips.io
actually you know this will be more fun
if we put them side by side so let's do
that
okay
so here we have github
uh and here we have uh streamlet and in
fact right now i'm in the
streamlet
workspace i'm going to switch over to my
own workspace here
okay so these are all my apps that i've
been working on i'm going to grab this
url that you see here on the left and
i'm going to uh let's create a new app
and let's paste uh this url
we can do some additional fancy stuff
here which i won't go into and we can
deploy it uh this time it already had
been deployed so uh so uh
uh so so it loaded really quickly
otherwise it has to build a container
but it takes it still quick and so here
we have a you know the the the same
app
sorry to introduce just a reminder that
we just have one more minute
oh okay okay
um and it's super cool stuff you can do
here so we can um
edit it for example in um in your source
repository so i'm gonna change like this
this select box
and turn it into a multi-select so how
would i do that
um
[Music]
so we go like this
come this out
and we'll commit this change
and there
it auto reloaded the app in fact it kept
the state which is like really amazing
so now this multi-select is a
is a uh is a it allows you to program
the layout and super bowl okay um so i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm way behind schedule
on this talk as it turns out so i'm
gonna go really quickly
and i'm going to say
um
uh this is just a really cool uh
technology uh it's already being used in
a ton of companies it has security built
in from the beginning uh it lets you you
can work with all your single sign-on
providers uh we're working with the
large cloud providers to provide
streamlets to uh in in a very secure way
to connect your data sources so if
that's something interesting to you
should uh contact us um and so i think
that uh you know python uh lets you do a
lot without demanding a lot of you uh to
me
that's really the the flip side of
simplicity is flow it's the ability to
build uh a lot of it not just one app
and make it a huge crazy project but
build a lot of things and we've seen
fortune 50 companies uh who've created
like a thousand streamlit apps uh in
production all running simultaneously in
the past year uh running various aspects
of their operations so that's like super
exciting the other thing i want to tell
you about in five seconds is community
uh this is a really important to us it's
a huge part of what makes it fun to work
at streamland and be part of streamlift
uh we really think about who we are in
the world these are our values be kind
um you know which is not just be
saccharine or or or or don't have candor
it means you know
it
means recognize the humanity and others
and i think that this actually plays out
throughout the entire uh throughout
everything that happens at extremely so
it's really fun to work here uh
you know uh we just had our offsite uh
our yearly upside in colorado and these
are many of the people who work at
streamlit and uh it's just uh i wanna
say shout out to all of them and say
thank you uh for for working with
streamline every day it's really fun
working with all of you
if you go to the gallery
you will see that um
there's a huge community of people who
are creating incredibly interesting
things
uh is streamlined and it's quite
inspirational and you can see all kinds
of uses and for machine learning and for
uh more traditional i suppose
dashboarding type applications i'm not
going to go into all of this stuff but
really cool uh you know if you go into
twitter and you search for streamlight
uh similarly to dash you'll see uh just
incredible amounts of energy i mean this
is it's just so so so cool i don't can't
even say this i think we're you know
we're still october 25th that's three
days ago and it just keeps going and
going okay um and uh oh custom
components really really cool so um
this is just like allowing people to to
create things uh you know and and extend
the value that the thing of streamless
uh here's a neat one that lets you
have a
webcam component uh this is a demo you
can also we can start it right here uh
and uh there we go
uh and so uh
and you know stop ahead and change
things so anyway that's super cool to
see the community also building a lot of
interesting components for streamlet
um
and uh oh there's tons and tons of uh
you know contributors to streamlet and i
want to thank all of them over 180 uh
streamlets
[Music]
118. adrian but if you don't
mind
oh okay i i may have maybe have 10 more
seconds to share one more demo
uh
and so finally i'll say hey you can also
there's a ton of just streamlet on uh
on github um and that i think is is
really neat uh
uh not only from the perspective of you
know seventy six thousand uh examples of
imports treatment as is tea that's not
that's really neat not only from the
perspective of there's a huge code
examples to see how you can use stream
in different ways but
it actually um
uh
it's so there's so much streamlet on the
online that in fact um over half the
fortune 50 is a streamlit there's oh
there's a cool book about streamlet
by a by a street by a data scientist but
anyway i'll get to the whole point here
which is that there's so much
streamlined on github at this point uh
that now
uh ais have learned to speak streamlight
automatically so this is a really
mind-bending demo where someone says an
app which shows price for google stock
and then they say from stream imports
limit sst import yahoo finance and this
entire app is written from scratch using
codecs uh
and and generates a working streamlit
app that shows google stock price really
this is something that you can try
yourselves this is really really
stunning so
i'll pause there i will end there and
say that the flip side of community is
power we think that all these things
come together in a really interesting
way in streamlit and so thank you so
much for your time and uh sorry for
going it over and uh looking forward to
the discussion
cancel that for all the cool stuff
adrian um now going back again to james
for the discussion topics
uh all right so that that concludes the
portion of this workshop where everyone
gets to uh present their own case for
their own library why it's interesting
and exciting and all of them are clearly
interesting and exciting
um
but this is the this last portion of it
is really the unique feature of this
workshop where you get to hear what each
library thinks about each other and all
the other libraries and how they relate
to each other
um and to start that off i'd like each
of the library authors to think of one
good and nice thing to say about the
another library
or all the other libraries if you want
but just something to point out that is
a strength of one of the other other
libraries something that um that that
other library does well
and so in let me see what order we were
going this order so probably
uh go backwards or this time adrian uh
you could have maybe uh two minutes to
say uh that sort of thing
two minutes okay cool uh yeah well i
mean there's there's first of all thank
you for setting this up this way jim
it's really cool and i do think that
like the larger picture of the python
data ecosystem being something that
we're all part of and trying to grow and
it's strong is i just love that framing
so um i mean we're where to start uh you
know uh voila i think is a very
beautiful way of connecting uh
uh extending the story of jupiter into
uh into this dashboarding framework and
of really connecting that story uh and
you know it i think it makes a lot of
sense if you're working in a jupiter
notebook to to create things and voila i
also just want to say you know obviously
jupiter itself is is basically a
stunning uh advancement in scientific
community in computing and we we
probably all wouldn't be here if not for
jupiter so uh shout out to that
community and and and the jupiter folks
um
you know uh very cool uh
i guess i'll say something about all of
them a very cool um
uh
uh um instagram thanking all the news uh
plotly dash uh demo uh where you know
the reactivity uh going back to python
is is really uh is really stunning and i
think that the the sort of basic set of
abstractions that you guys have uh put
together make a lot of sense and hold
well together uh and then finally um
for a panel uh i think you know
obviously a great deal of work has gone
into uh visualizing large data sets and
uh and also uh creating real-time
dashboards which i don't think you
showed mark but it's something that's
really neat about panels so uh you know
all
i'm struck in many ways by the
commonalities among these projects
behind there
okay thank you very much um
uh sylvain
hey um
yeah so i i don't i didn't really know
stream it so well but i think this demo
of by adrian was absolutely stunning so
every time i've seen examples of
streamlets it seemed and it's obviously
so polished and you know we'll finish
that you know it's it's it seems to be a
very impressive
framework
uh
regarding dash i think we've looked a
lot into dash recently uh specifically
with respect to scalability and you know
because they have a so different like
execution model from voila and
and we were like trying to think of you
know what we could you know
do to be closer to dash's uh scalability
so
that's definitely and like we're
obviously good friends with the partly
folks and who are building upon ipad
widgets for for the library as well so
uh clearly yeah i would say dash's
scalability is
what we're what is really striking
and um regarding panels so it's really
funny because i think the first panel
released was announced at the same
jupiter community workshop as voila
so philip was attending and we both
announced the
first release in the same in the same at
the same event
and uh and so yeah i mean a panel is
sort of the natural
uh you know
top layer on top of
you know the whole of this framework and
like all of that stack and so it makes a
lot of sense for building applications
with with you know with large amounts of
data so
yeah
that's it
all right thank you
mark
yes thanks so there's a lot of good
things to say but if i should say one
thing
so for for streamlit it's really if you
have one function and you want to make
it interactive it's really easy with
streamlit
and for walla well wallet just provides
what the jupiter uses they they need and
crave and and so on it it really
provides something for that community
that fits really well in there and then
i would say for
for a dash well dash really it speaks
the language language of enterprise you
could say and it's really good at that
all right and uh nicholas
uh thanks everyone um yeah i love this
part uh i so so streamlight i just think
that the developer extreme experience of
writing a stream laid out app is just
lovely like it's so fluent um and the
the automated caching uh mechanism is
great and something i'm very jealous of
uh so you guys have done an incredible
job of sort of like bridging that gap
um
for voila i actually think it's it's
sort of similar the thing i really love
about voila
is
if you came to my talk earlier today i
really care a lot about data scientists
being able to build their own tools
really quickly uh data scientists spend
a lot of their time in jupiter um and i
just love the fact that you're just like
in jupiter and then
and then you're you're in voila so that
that that like no extra step aspect of
it uh really really seals the deal for
me and i i love voila for that um and
and the fact that it's um you know uh
like like totally open source um
uh and part of the ecosystem um anyway
it's great um and panel i i'm i'm always
very impressed with the uh the sort of
scope of vision and sort of unifying
concepts uh that that the hollow vase
community comes out with um you know to
have the whole like there's some
beautiful diagrams on their website of
like kind of the vision of uh everything
to do with with computation and viz uh
and and holovis and hg plot and how they
connect to every other part of the of
the ecosystem um and uh and that's
that's just like a real strength uh of
uh of what panel and hall of famers do
so um
you know thank you all for for
everything that you do for this
community um and it's something that i
look i like kind of look over the fence
sometimes in other communities and they
have this kind of monoculture of
everyone uses the one library um and
people think that we here in python are
a little like fragmented and weird and
people can't just decide but this is a
huge strength of our communities that we
have so many amazing options and people
working together and interoperating
thanks
very cool okay i uh thank you all those
are really insightful comments and i'm
actually going to read the uh listen to
the recording later and kind of uh think
about each one of them those are those
are really helpful thanks everybody
um i collected some votes for discussion
topics from the um
slack channel and uh there were two
votes each for numbers three and four so
let's go ahead and start with those um
number three uh if each author could
sort of just say uh very succinctly
uh what does your library offer so for
exporting to a standalone html page that
you could send in an email or provide to
somebody who doesn't have python running
so uh go back to the original order so
uh nicholas
uh good question so any given uh
certainly plotly figure can be exported
to html uh a dash application
uh does not does not have a sort of
obvious way of doing that
within dash enterprise it's possible to
export to pdf pretty easily
but that's uh that's something where we
don't um
sort of architecture a little bit
challenging the main purpose of dash is
to connect the ui to a python function
so without the python piece there's not
a whole lot that we can do
okay thanks uh mark
yeah
so i think this is where panel has
something unique you can think about
video recording actually that's what
panel can do so if you have an
interactive application running on a
server then it can actually like run
through all the combinations of sliders
or widgets or something like like that
at least to a limit and sort of record
the application and then you have a
static html application you can share
with a colleague by an email or slack or
something like that
well
uh
so then
yeah so the answer for vola is that for
this purpose we use the auditors from
the jupiter stack and specifically nb
convert the latest release of the
convert includes the tour called deja vu
which is another you know part of my
plot to
force americans to type access
and
so deja vu turns
uh notebooks into html or pdfs through a
headless browser and can apply it has
the same basic and default options as
voila and it can apply volatile
templates so if you type deja vu in
notebook or if you use the pnd convert
endpoint in jupyter lab you get the pdf
corresponding to your dashboard or html
depending on
cool adrian
uh so uh so streamlit doesn't have an
export html feature uh we actually
originally did uh but uh we we got rid
of it and really focused on um
on making streamline apps extremely
shareable so the example that i showed
you uh was you click to deploy and then
uh this url is given to you that you can
share anywhere in the world
and streamline cloud which is coming out
next tuesday it's been in beta with
about 600 companies
is about making that possible inside of
organizations so we
really focus on
creating interactive artifacts and then
we want to make it a really beautiful
shareable experience to pass those
artifacts around securely in an
organization or with the whole world
all right well thanks for that sort of
segue into number four uh so maybe uh
just one little quick uh distinction
between number four and five if each of
you could talk about four but compared
to five the difference between deploying
one of your apps for all the world to
see or deploying behind a firewall
i'll just keep rotating i guess um so uh
dash is built on flask uh flask is
pretty easy to deploy uh folks deploy uh
dash applications publicly on heroku all
the time you can do it for i believe
free or small dollar amounts um we do
not today have a uh plotly hosted kind
of shiny apps type thing or uh or
streamlight share system although we're
thinking about it um
beyond heroku you can deploy it on
basically you know any of the recipes
that exist to deploy a flask app on like
digitalocean or anything else
that broadly holds for internal systems
as well you can deploy a dash
application uh anywhere you like and of
course for internal systems we love it
if you if you license dash enterprise to
do that which is a whole set of tools
that allow you to control who can who
can access your dash apps um so you can
use that both publicly or internally if
you want although the majority of our
customers
do so internally
so yeah again you can deploy almost
anywhere but not on python anywhere
because they don't support web sockets
and one of the unique things about panel
is actually that you don't have to buy
an enterprise subscription or whatever
to get authentication it's built into
pen
yeah so you
voila really uses the jupyter stack
for that purpose as well so we document
deploying voda specifically
uh on top of a running jupiter hub
instance or on a heroku or even a binder
so if you need some specific single
sign-on uh
plug-in you can just use the
corresponding jupyter plug-in
okay and adrian
uh sorry are we i'm just gonna perhaps
combine four and five please so
okay cool so um yeah so streamlit has a
uh public uh sharing uh uh service
called share.streamlet.io
um we've just uh really
lifted the cap on the number of public
apps that you can share used to be three
now it's infinity um that's because we
had actually the head of uh of uh uh
platform development at heroku joined
stream at a year and a half ago and has
helped us really build a scalable system
for sharing apps so that's pretty
exciting um right now there are over 30
000 apps shared and streamlined apps are
going to be viewed 1.5 million times
this quarter so we're really excited
about that uh and then um
the the same technology is used uh in
streamlight cloud to allow companies to
securely share apps with one another
we have a bunch of additional technology
that lets you do secure connection to
data sources and so forth it is a sas
service so that is the security model
that we offer
in addition yeah streamla can be
deployed uh you know in heroku and all
these other things if you go to our docs
we have we encourage that usage we show
you how to put it on gcp on amazon on
heroku on wherever digital ocean etc
um and then you know a lot of uh big
companies uh have actually created their
own streamlet uh uh basically
systems inside uh the company so uh you
know famously uh uber famously for us
uber created uh added stream up to their
data science workbench which is a lot
you know allows all uh employees to to
deploy streamlit apps and so
um what we
do is um you know for large companies
like that at present streamlet sharing
is usually not the right solution for
security reasons and then we uh help
them create their own streamlined deploy
so that's the internal to their uh vpc
or on-prem
okay thank you very much all right we've
got um
two more that have about two votes
that's seven and twenty so um
seven how much do you have to know web
technologies javascript or html and i
guess if you want you can contrast it
with number nine which is that if you do
know these things how easily can you um
can you customize and get into the nitty
gritty so maybe go back and forth
between those two do you have to know
and can you use it if you do know
so again let's just keep the same order
it makes it so much easier so nicholas
yeah sure thing so um given the dash is
based on on react you can use any react
component that exists been wrapped in
dash
do you you don't have to know any
javascript to use to use dash components
if you do know javascript you can either
build your own components or wrap
existing components
do you need to know html and css you
don't need to you can use a component
suite like dash bootstrap components
that lets you kind of work at a slightly
higher level
if you have a preferred sort of
framework for doing stuff you can either
find or build
a set of components that use it
but if you do know html and css uh you
can you can use you know html.div and p
and span and all the css stuff you want
uh so we really do try and give you
access to the to the full um
the full breadth of the stack um
and and you know i showed a bunch of
different apps that really did have
quite different looks and feels um and
and most of those apps actually that i
showed were uh were built by uh not by
polly employees like these are apps that
that you know folks have successfully
and happily built so um we like we like
the balance that we're striking there
thank you
um mark
yes
so as a beginner you don't need to know
anything about javascript html or css
for yeah that's that's what we want to
provide with panel
but we all we also want you to not meet
dead ends so if you have a friend
friends colleague some something like
that you can call in
uh
rockstar front-end developer then you
can use javascript html and css to build
custom components
with javascript or typescript react web
components whatever
okay thanks
so bad
yeah you don't need to know any
javascript or css or html to write a
voila
notebook because you just need to know
how to make a notebook uh however if you
do
then you can create new jupyter widgets
very easily so which are the equivalent
of manual components i would say
and
another thing that you can do if you are
proficient in short-term development is
create a new voila template for example
you could make a template for your
company that has the little both your
company some boilerplate
uh you know legally at the bottom that
that type of stuff
[Music]
uh adrian
uh yeah so uh similar story uh you don't
need to know extremely i you don't need
to know html and css
uh we try to make uh sort of the basic
components that you'd want to use to
make an app available and super easy to
use um that's part of the point uh you
can use uh
we are also based on react so that's the
simplest uh
thing to use but we also allow custom
components to iframe and anything they
want and that allows you to use view uh
people have used elm um to create
components for streamlight and that's
how for example the webcam components
that i showed you earlier and of course
uh was created and of course you know
this uh streamless emphasis on community
means that we also uh really have an
active community around building
components and sharing uh other kinds of
bits of snippets of of code online and
so if you go to shimmer.ios components
uh you can see it lots of examples of um
of interesting components also mark runs
awesome streamlight which is a great way
to find out other cool examples of
stream that use and components
very cool
okay so
looks like 20 has a lot of lists uh okay
applications this is uh suggested by
nicholas actually so nicholas
application that library x is not
suitable for
yeah um
so so it's painful to talk about this no
um so you know we would like dash to be
to be uh really suitable for for
everything else for everything uh i
would say that that where dash is
probably weakest right now and this
maybe connects to 12 here is sort of the
the experience of sort of starting in a
notebook and moving to an app um and so
if you if you have something built in a
notebook with ipi widgets
and you've built yourself a small tool
and you want to kind of like
switch to or upgrade to being to
building a a richer app um
and you want to do so with dash that's
that's more difficult uh and i would say
the sort of activation energy to kind of
jump out of your your notebook flow if
that's where you're at uh to to start
building an uh a dash app is probably
the the biggest impediment to using dash
right now um so so i would say it's not
us it's not so suitable for building
yourself like a one-off little tool uh
when you're when you're in your notebook
flow
[Music]
cool
mark sorry i didn't hear the question
what is panel not really suitable for
compared to these other tools
yeah so sometimes people they ask me
should i build a sas application and
earn money on it and have a lot of
customers and that's not really what
it's for it's like for
super user tools inside an enterprise
inside a university inside a
an organization i would say
[Music]
okay
so then
yeah i think uh the b sensor also
applies to to voila uh what are really
only skills as much as you can provide
compute environments for each user
and
you have for you know it's a it's it's
an embarrassingly powerful problem so
you can certainly scan it up you know by
spawning more
parts in the kubernetes cluster that
type of stuff but
um
it's really the opposite model to dash
which is like completely stateless and
it's really based on a normal you know
web server that you can you know
uh i guess put behind the load balancer
or the type of stuff so really there is
a limit to the scale but you can you
know deploy every dashboard
oh and andrea
um
uh
yeah so
there's there's many ways of answering
this question um
i i think it one way that i was just
thinking of is um if you if you go to uh
roadmap.streamlet.io or tradeoff.ios
roadmap uh you can see sort of all the
things that we're working on and in many
ways that's kind of um a picture of of
where we'd like the uh the the
the the app to go um and so i'm just
looking at this right now we're working
on um workspace invitations multi-page
apps custom subdomains perhaps um
ability to set up third party analytics
uh st.user which is the ability to sort
of tie user identity into various
aspects of your app sd.database a tiny
no sql database for every app and stream
the cloud by the way this is none of
this is secret you can see this all
online a drawable canvas widget uh
anchors everywhere tabs container pop-up
containers um so
lots and lots of cool things coming down
the line and each one of the the lack of
each one of those is is certainly uh
painful to us uh but we're excited to be
bringing them to you all in the coming
months
okay thank you um it looks like there
was confusion about between 11 and 12
on the chat i see but in any case i
think 12 has been covered by some by
each of the uh discussions so how about
number 11 some of the votes for 12 for
were apparently for number 11. so how
good is your app framework at
creating complex apps that have
multi-page uh or involved
some form of state particularly state
between multiple pages that sort of
thing
so uh nicholas
yeah um so i think it's it's really
important to to highlight with dash so
we have a stateless architecture
and that is stateless sort of from the
point of view of the server that's the
kind of very low level technical detail
but um dash is actually extremely well
suited to building sort of very complex
um complex applications so multi-page is
pretty easy there's a dash component for
the the location people do this all the
time um
that one video that i showed like two
seconds of i encourage people to watch
it because it's pretty impressive so
folks are building a quite powerful you
know multi-stage tools uh out of dash
where you know either you upload a file
you run some process you used to give
some more user input drag things around
um uh so so dash is actually pretty good
at that um and the complexity doesn't
scale too badly like it's not your app
doesn't like explode in complexity when
you when you build this the the reactive
model uh the stateless sort of pure
functional model scales really really
well with that you can break your app up
into little little files have separate
little functions unit test them and
decorate them
and so that's i feel like one of the
real strengths of dash
cool no
yeah so i feel like multi-page apps
that's really a strength of panel it's
really coming out of you can just have
individual files each of them are an app
and then you serve them up and they're
sort of connected
so that's really a strength
and then you can say the architecture of
yeah panel
and streamlet and walla is the opposite
of dashrite it's it has state
for panel we have session state so the
individual user can have like that
the state of a data frame or something
or a plot
but you can also share state across
sessions so if you have like an
you're loading expensive data or
something you can you can do it once and
then you can share it with across users
cool so that
yeah uh sorry i was looking for the
unmute button so
yeah voila is a stage four uh
application so it depends on what the
complexity is i would say uh if you have
a very complex model in the back end
that requires a lot of data you can
certainly do that with voda easily
then in terms of the complexity of the
front end like multi-page whatever it
all is limited by the widget framework
that you decide to use you could use
like advanced ones like apple beautify
and which are mobile friendly if you
just use the basic app i will just
control you can only go so far you know
because you
you know
then in order to make complex layouts
you need to start
using you know
nested widgets and
edge boxes and v boxes which which can
you know
only go so far when you know if you
really want to have something like a
i don't know a neutral nuclear plant
control panel that's that may not be the
best one so then i think you need to use
it like a more
a really good release framework to build
this kind of application
okay adrian
um
so uh yeah
our customers do create very complex
multi-page apps in streamlift they also
create stateful apps as described in a
number of ways we took a very long time
to release
our own first party state
abstractions in streamlit and the reason
is because
i guess perhaps to a fault we're
obsessed with uh just the simplicity of
the of the ui and uh and the uh the
developer experience uh we haven't yet
released a first-party way of creating
multi-page apps
they're certainly creatable i'm looking
at our own internal app dashboard right
now which is a multi-page app and we
have uh
we can point to many examples of big
companies uh but we're working on trying
to
really bring an api that we think
expresses that idea of multi-page apps
and also sort of multi-function
computation
in a way that's super uh easy for the
developer and just as importantly super
understandable and consumable for the
viewer
very cool
okay it looks like the next most common
is 14 rendering large data sets
nicholas
yeah
i would say that that sort of just works
like dash doesn't really have a whole
lot to say about about the size of the
data that you're that you're running uh
it's mostly kind of the conduit for that
so um people use uh people use dash to
front extremely large data sets you know
connecting to
upstream servers like i don't know
snowflake databricks rapids
desk and so on
and we interoperate really well with
with stuff like data shader and
holoviews so there's not really anything
in the way of you using uh the usual the
usual uh python suspects um i linked to
that one app that has a you know a data
shader overlay on a map and a desk back
end um at the nvidia gtc keynote a
couple of years ago a year ago it's been
a long pandemic
they talked about using uh using rapids
and dash uh to sort of track real-time
covert infection data um
so yeah
dash is sort of just python and you can
use all the usual suspects for large
data sets
sounds good mark
yeah
so i would say panel and hollowvis is
really driving the big data
visualizations via data shader and other
stuff
so yes you can and especially also think
that
actually the that you have state in your
application makes it sort of easier to
make interactive
big data visualizations
okay so that
um
yeah
once again i think i'll give the same
answer it's very orthogonal to voila the
size of the data is really eternal true
to
to how voila works voda has been used in
combination with uh troll such as all
these or vex for example for actually
doing some data destination for plotting
and whatnot and just like you can do in
the notebook
cool all right adrian
um
i i'll i'll be a little bit uh
controversial and say that um
while i do think that the size of the
data uh
sources are in a sense orthogonal to
these frameworks um
i it's
it's it's easy to say uh you know you
can't necessarily hold a
you know
paradight data frame in memory for
example uh and it's easy to say oh with
python it's all programmable so
therefore it all works for large data
frames because you can always do
something in python that fixes that i
think that's true and that's certainly
true of streamlit as well
but uh you know in terms of uh built-in
basic primitives to do those kinds of
things uh you know uh streamlet uh and
actually i think many of these other
frameworks with perhaps the exception of
panel i'm not sure how that works uh are
are actually really not designed for
giant data sets and they have to be sort
of wired together with uh on top of
spark or other things in order to make
that possible uh that's certainly true
with streamline as well um i i would
also say that a a minor but kind of cool
thing about streamlight is that because
it the the basic framework is that
you're running a um
a script and scripts themselves are
designed to work on you know arbitrarily
long computation uh uh streamlight was
really designed to make it possible to
create uh progress bars and other kinds
of things that sort of show you the the
progress of a long computation as it's
happening um and that's something that
uh that that's one way and perhaps a
slightly non-trivial way in which we
make it slightly easier to work with
large data sets
okay looks like we have time for one
more question and then and maybe a last
statement from each of the libraries
about things that you've learned so um
why don't you go ahead and combine them
because number 19 is the next one in
votes and it's intended slash mainline
application for x like what is the
prototypical reason somebody would use
this library
and so if each of the um participants
could have let's say we have seven
minutes so two minutes a piece uh to
talk about that for each for your
library what is this really for and
anything else you want to throw in in
that two minutes
uh nicholas go
yeah for sure there's a question about
accessibility which i think is really
important so i'll i'll spend 30 seconds
on it so accessibility uh in terms of
sort of keyboard navigation um and aria
tags and readability um is something
that is primarily driven by the by the
component layer and the front-end layer
um so i will say that within dash uh our
built-in components are not particularly
accessible and it's something that we'd
like to work on and we'd left some help
with
and that uh uh custom components that
are built sort of the accessibility
thereof um depends on depends on the
custom component so that's not something
that that we do an amazing job at but we
would we would love to learn more about
how to do that
um
the intended main line application for
dash i would say is basically um you
know i kind of think about it as the
last mile in some ways to uh to data
science projects is to is to
provide a user interface and a way for
humans to connect with data and models
um so be that you know kind of a
read-only interface to sort of do data
exploration
or um a sort of bridge to connect the
work of data scientists and non-data
scientists uh you know people who have
access to python code um and you know so
giving their output and bringing people
in who who have expertise about a
particular domain um
uh to to bear into it to sort of work
with python code so that's that's sort
of the
the high-level main line application for
uh for dash um
and um by way of closing like this has
been a really fun session it's been
really nice to have everyone sort of
side by side and be able to kind of let
everyone
uh speak for themselves so thank you
thank you mark
yeah so the intended or mainline
application for a panel is probably like
domain applications
just as before like if you are a
scientist you want to make
something for yourself something for
your colleague something for your
stakeholders your manager
maybe something for a customer i also
see
people coming out of cern working with
big data making aviation tracking
applications or stuff like that so yes
thanks so much
yeah
i would say that um the main
use case for vola is if you have for
example a team of data scientists who
are using jupiter and know how to make
nice jupiter notebooks they don't have
to learn anything new they can just turn
these notebooks into
voila dashboards
if they want to apply a template with
the company you know
visual identity and you can easily you
know share
search with a dashboard with the users
of a jupiter hub
deployment so this is you know really
you don't need to know that you're
making a dashboard in order to make the
dashboard so that's really the main
thing and in the future i mean it's
going to be even easier jupiter is
really making strides and with respect
to social features
like collaborative editing just standing
into jupiter lab and now we are going to
have like an experience that's really
closer to like google docs and that type
of stuff and within that framework where
you can really have like collaborative
um
environments uh i think that voda is
going to become even more
you know easy to use and easy to uh like
an even better tool for sharing
information within a team or a company
cool thanks uh adrian
um
uh similar to to what uh the others have
said here you know uh streamlet is a
superpower which lets data scientists um
build apps without uh needing to know
really anything beyond the python stack
uh i think the thing that where we
really shine and where we've really put
a lot of focus in and it's just sort of
a thread through all the demos i showed
you was we really wanted to make it
possible to create apps so quickly and
to iterate that on them so quickly this
is something that and therefore to not
view apps as a sort of rarified thing
that you do every now and then but
rather as a sort of byproduct of the
data science workflow that you just have
a thousand apps why not ten thousand
apps uh and so uh that's something that
we both are seeing internally at
streamlit actually um you know there's a
problem with this data source oh here's
an app that lets you introspect that
data source and find all of the mistakes
and i just created it in half an hour
and i just shared it with you and by the
way by the end of the day we're not
going to need it anymore the app's gone
um that's just super cool and uh and and
then make them extremely shareable and
extremely usable by others inside of the
organization and so uh yeah we're seeing
with a big automaker you know for the
first year it was
you know five apps and then it was 30
apps and now it's a thousand dots and so
that that sort of
suddenly cambrian explosion of building
apps really quickly iterating on them
super quickly fixing the code during the
meeting and having it update live that's
what we're really focused on
very cool
okay well i'd really like to thank all
of the uh panelists for such insightful
comments about your own libraries and
everyone else's that was really helpful
and thank you to the audience for the uh
questions that you uh piped in there and
for your uh supportive comments in the
chat that's been really helpful and
thank you to the moderator and to pi
data in general for hosting this and uh
setting this all up
it's been a great experience thank you
thank you so much thanks james
thank you thank you
thank you everyone
you